it's early morning in the Bahamian
island of Abaco and Esther is sifting
through what's left of her home the same
house she's lived in for the last 56
years don't worry about the tanks you
can open get things back my life and
this hurricane was more than a hurricane
you call it a hurricane but something
else was going on with this down the
road at a nearby airstrip a chaotic
scene is playing out the first airplanes
have arrived to evacuate survivors of
Hurricane durian tra neubel is here with
her children but there are hundreds of
others trying to evacuate and there
simply aren't enough planes it's a
disaster a lot of people live them has
passed away a lot of bodies it's it's
ridiculous no help no homes there's no
shelter and it's really really bad here
driving down the road toward Marsh
Harbor it becomes clear why so many
people are fleeing this region of the
Bahamas was the worst hit by the storm
this is about as bad as hurricane damage
gets as you can see the scene here in
Marsh Harbor is nightmarish there is
debris everywhere there are boats in
front of people's driveways the
floodwaters have not receded yet and for
thousands of residents who have lost
their homes here that nightmare is far
from over for many of the injured and
displaced one of the only places to go
is this hospital the only health
facility left standing after the storm
minutes to even check in they will even
take or get from here or go there and
move there and then give you know hope
for nothing you know there's no hope for
nothing they just leave you there in
this side it's
it could be months before life returns
to normal on Abaco some of those who
have managed to evacuate may never
return in the meantime there are still
hundreds of others waiting for their
turn to get out my new Ezra pollo al
Jazeera Marsh Harbor the Bahamas